how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU phase four hasn't even started yet
but we're all wondering what the next
big Avengers in-game level event is
going to be and what it's going to look
like
we know that tons of new characters over
the next 10 years are going to be
entering the MCU including the Fantastic
Four a bunch of x-men and a bunch of new
villains as well but what's the next
huge level event where all of these
characters are going to combine in one
movie like they did in infinity war and
endgame and when are we going to get it
unfortunately we probably have a few
years to wait before we get this event
but fortunately it seems like we know
what the event will be and it looks like
there were some Easter eggs dropped for
this next level event in Avengers end
game and then not too long after that
and spider-man far from home it looks
like we got some more Easter eggs
related to the same ass story
and although this next huge event is
probably years and years away it doesn't
mean they can't start setting up the
story in the next Avengers so we'll
break down these Easter eggs that you
need to know that look like they're
setting up the next big event in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a Thanos Funko pop all you
got to do to enter subscribe like the
video and leave a comment down below so
recently a redditor by the name of
waffles pls pointed out some very
similar things between the Hulk and
Avengers in game end The Hulk and the
secret war storyline he pointed out that
the Hulk holding up the building and
Avengers in game after Thanos shoots it
with a bunch of missiles looks an awful
lot like Hulk holding up a mountain in
the secret war storyline and it really
does but that's actually because the
Russo brothers have already confirmed
that this is in fact a scene taken from
secret Wars
specifically the cover of secret Wars
number four now the Russo brothers again
did confirm this so this is an official
secret Wars Easter Egg much like in game
in this issue the avengers headquarters
gets destroyed but instead of a building
falling on top of the Avengers it's a
mountain and the Hulk holds it up
keeping it from crushing all of the
Avengers now in this secret Wars there
are many different members of the
Avengers
the x-men and the Fantastic Four in fact
it's mr. fantastic who figures out how
to blow a hole in the mountain to get
all of the heroes out now we know that
the x-men and the Fantastic Four are
coming to the MCU eventually Kevin Feige
has already announced that and if you
followed my channel for a while you know
that I've been saying for some time now
that Avengers secret Wars battle world
is going to be the huge event where the
Avengers the x-men and the Fantastic
Four along with many other heroes will
come together and the rusa brothers have
put an Avengers Secret Wars Easter egg
in Avengers in game but here's the
kicker this isn't the only Secret Wars
Easter Egg to exist in the MCU and the
Russo brothers have said that they will
come back to direct a Secret Wars film
so let's talk about the next Avengers
Secret Wars Easter egg that is in
spider-man far from home this easter egg
comes from the jet scene where Peter
Parker is designing a new suit while
ac/dc is blaring over the speaker system
while Peter is going over different
suits that they can choose from the
camera kinda lingers on a few of those
suits and reddit user a k2 sub has
Reshard the image while attempting to
match those with their comic-book
counterparts there are a few different
awesome suits here but as we can see the
one on the far right looks an awful lot
like spider-man's Secret Wars suit it
looks very very identical which could be
our second Secret Wars Easter Egg and as
I mentioned in the beginning the
Fantastic Four are also a part of the
Secret Wars story and there happened to
be some fantastic for Easter eggs in
spider-man far from home the Easter Egg
comes at the end of spider-man 5 from
home where Peter Parker is swinging
through the city of New York going to
meet MJ Peter lands on the old Avengers
tower which is now being renovated since
the headquarters has moved and a sign in
front of the building says we can't wait
to show you what comes next and then it
says the numbers 1 2 3 implying that for
the Fantastic Four is coming next to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe also implying
that the new mysterious building that
has taken the place of the Avengers
tower could be the Baxter building the
headquarters of the Fantastic Four so
there's a few different Easter eggs that
have come from Avengers endgame and
spider-man far from home about Secret
Wars and the Fantastic Four who of
course are in Secret Wars but here's
where it gets really exciting the
Brothers have said numerous times that
they'll only come back to direct a
Marvel movie if they get to come back
and direct Secret Wars and then not too
long ago it was revealed that Kevin
Feige and the Russo brothers continued
to talk to each other about MCU projects
well we know that the Russo brothers
aren't coming back anytime soon they've
gone off and started their own company
so why is Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios talking to them about
projects well it could be because all of
these different projects are going to
lead up to this huge event that the
Russo brothers are going to come back
and direct and perhaps that's why we've
gotten a couple of different Avengers
secret Wars Easter eggs and a few MCU
films it does seem like Avengers secret
Wars is coming and the story could start
as early on as Avengers 5 the next
Avengers film and eventually lead up to
Avengers battle world a story in which
the multiverse and different universes
combine and that will be the next huge
event but let me know what you think
about these Easter eggs and what would
you think if the next Avengers film
revolved around secret Wars
let me know what you think in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like the video and subscribe stay up to
date on all things relating to the MCU
for live updates you can follow me on
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof